The general feeling amongst physicists,
for the last hundred years
is that we need to quantize space time
just as we quantized every other field.
But reconciling gravity with quantum
theory
is one of the great challenges of physics.
Thus far
we've been hopelessly unsuccessful.
And so think, we're at a point
where we ought to really question
whether this drive
and this challenge to quantize gravity,
whether that really
was the right thing to do
My name is Jonathan Oppenheim.
I'm a physicist at University
College London. And myself
and my students have proposed
a theory of gravity
where matter remains quantum,
but somehow gravity is treated
classically.
It's an attempt to reconcile the fact
that our current theory of gravity,
which is general relativity,
is inconsistent with quantum mechanics.
In physics we have these two frameworks,
quantum mechanics and classical mechanics,
all the particles and all the fields
and different forces and electromagnetism
and all that we know in nature
that we've discovered,
they all obey quantum theory.
But quantum theory doesn't
describe gravity.
Our theory of gravity is general
relativity discovered by Einstein
And it is a theory of spacetime.
So it tells us that spacetime bends
and it is not a quantum theory at all.
The general feeling amongst physicists
for the last hundred years
is that gravity is a force
just like any other force,
and therefore it should be quantized,
just like every other force.
And, fit into the framework of quantum
theory.
But gravity is different.
gravity is very simple.
In some ways,
almost all of gravity is just that.
Clocks run at different
speeds in different places.
And that amazingly gives you
the curvature of space time
gravity is very much about the arena
or the background in which matter moves.
So you have this quantized matter
which evolves in time and moves in space.
and this background space time
appears to be a necessary part
of how we describe quantum theory.
So let's say you believe
that we should quantize space-time
what we're doing is we're quantizing
how fast clocks run.
And it turns out if you try and quantize
that, you're essentially quantizing
the speed of time.
And if you quantize the speed of time,
what you find is that time becomes frozen
things don't evolve at all.
So this is the immediate problem
that people grappled with
when they were trying to quantized gravity
and we've been stuck on that ever since.
the black hole information paradox
or annoyance or problem,
however you want to describe it,
is probably
one of the most fascinating conundrums
we have in physics.
it somehow seems to hold the key
to the way to reconcile
gravity and quantum theory.
This problem
which comes about because of Hawking's
discovery that black holes
appear to thermally radiate.
So if you throw known a quantum state,
a known item into a black hole,
then the black hole will just radiate
in a way thermally, in a way that seems
to completely destroy the information
that was thrown into the black hole.
If you believe in a fully quantum
theory of gravity, you're pretty well
compelled to believe that information
has to come out of a black hole.
And therefore,
you have a bit of a paradox,
But It's only a paradox
if you believe that physics
somehow has to be deterministic, predicting
everything with certainty.
It's not a paradox if you don't believe
that physics is deterministic,
if you believe that there can be noise
and stochasticity and randomness,
if you believe that,
then it's not really a paradox at all.
You throw in a known state
into the black hole
and it comes out random,
and that's just the way life is.
And I think
a lot of phyisicists are very uncomfortable
if there's a fundamental stochasticity,
or randomness.
Kg squared
6 seconds meters to the minus.
The
idea that we can consistently
couple quantum systems
and classical systems has been around
since the nineties
and it was exciting to me
that these two frameworks
somehow can be made to fit together.
if space time is fundamentally
the classical background in which matter
moves, then things become easier
in many different ways.
So, for example,
you now can have an evolving spacetime.
The black hole information paradox
no longer is a paradox.
Information can be destroyed
if the background spacetime is classical.
And so what we, you know, myself
or my students were able to prove
is that any consistent theory of coupling
between classical degrees of freedom
and quantum degrees of freedom
have to be fundamentally stochastic.
Any theory in which gravity
is fundamentally classical
has to have this randomness.
And the amount of randomness
you have to have is a lot.
Ten to the minus one upper bound.
and then the lower bound
is ten to the -40.
So a few years ago, after
I'd given a talk on the theory,
I got into a discussion with Carlo
Rovelli, who's one of the founders of
loop quantum gravity.
And as a result of that discussion,
we formulated a bet with 5000 to 1 odds
on whether spacetime
is fundamentally quantum or not.
Geoff Pennington, who's a leading string
theorist, also joined in on the BET.
if I win,
I will get 5000 items from each of them,
maybe some olive oil or a little dram
of whiskey maybe, a packet of crisps
And so what I like about the bets
is that they force us to,
first of all,
make the bet precise in a way
that can be tested experimentally,
because I think
that's important that we can test
our beliefs experimentally.
we have these experiments
that we're proposing
looking for randomness
in the gravitational field, which are,
I would say, an indirect test
of a quantum theory of gravity in that
they're maybe more of a test
of a classical theory of gravity.
But of
course, if you don't find randomness
and noise in the gravitational field,
then you can rule out the classical theory
of gravity.
Blah, blah, blah,
So we measure the gravitational field,
say, produced by a one kilogram mass,
and we can measure how much noise
there is in a precision test of gravity.
And then we can go out and we can measure
how long we can put
a massive object in superposition.
So you imagine a gold atom, for example,
And those two experiments squeeze
any theory in which gravity is treated
fundamentally.
Classically,
it squeezes it from two directions,
We're all really struggling
to solve this problem.
We've been struggling for a hundred years.
And so the those experiments
will determine the outcome of the bet.